estamos en la cabecera de la marcha
indígena de la mina indígena que aquí en
cali se está dirigiendo a este barrio de
meléndez para apoyar a las marchas al
paro nacional que está viviendo colombia
desde el miércoles 28 de abril la mina
indígena
asegura que cali hoy ha asegurado que
cali es el lugar en el que se tienen que
quedar ya que ha sido el epicentro de
las protestas en colombia y además se
quieren unir al pueblo colombiano para
protestar contra los abusos policiales y
contra la situación económica y de
problemática social que vive el país
hablamos con uno de los consejeros
indígenas presentes aquí hoy al gobierno
nacional nosotros la minga se trasladó
hasta cali para manifestarnos también en
contra las políticas pero lo vamos a
hacer de una manera pacífica por eso le
pedimos el grande favor de que retire la
fuerza pública del espacio andy va a
estar la minga apoyando al pueblo de
aquí de de cali que se está desde el 28
está movilizando vamos a acompañarlo